So one of the things that I think is fascinating about all of what we're talking
about here is that it's not just about gender and sex and sexuality,
but this is also leaking into all sorts of other things,
talking about ethnicity and color of skin and all of that.
Uh,
you've written a bit about this.
I have,
yeah.
I wrote about how a university applications,
and particularly Harvard has been discriminating against Asians for decades.
Um,
and how to the point where Asians when they apply to university,
will want to hide their ethnicity in hopes of that.
That's going to give them a fair chance of actually getting into the school.
Yeah.
So,
all right,
so somebody that's watching this right now that doesn't know about this,
they're gonna go,
wait a minute.
Why would Harvard discriminate against Asian people?
Cause apparently there are too many Asians there.
If it's based solely on sat scores and meritocracy,
um,
there's a very high proportion of Asian students.
And so in the name of quote unquote diversity and inclusion,
um,
Asian students get penalized.
So this to me is the most blatant example of why this diversity stuff is
complete nonsense.
Because people on face value,
it seems nice.
We want to help people,
we want to help groups that maybe have struggled more for whatever reason we
should.
And,
and there's probably many good ways to do that.
Maybe investing in more education or whatever else.
I'm,
I'm happy to hear your,
your thoughts on that,
but what they take as a good thought then they don't think all the way through,
which means,
okay,
now we're going to have to punish people who have worked very hard and done
everything right.
And by and large,
the Asian community,
whether it's Chinese or Japanese or Korean or whatever else,
have worked really hard and put a focus on education and family.
And then what is the result of that?
It's now harder,
if not almost impossible at some level to get into Harvard.
And the craziest thing,
I don't understand why people think this is acceptable.
And even when I wrote that column,
I had a number of Asians reach out to me and say,
you know,
don't,
don't be used as a token for the far right.
And I'm totally okay with this.
This is fair.
And I'm thinking,
you know,
what are you on?
What was it about the times do an op Ed I think by an Asian woman from around
the state.
Yeah.
Saying that this is okay.
And I,
I just,
I mean,
what do you do with,
I don't know,
what do you do with that you are fighting for true.
We're quality.
Yeah.
That is simply not what they're fighting for.
I think it's indoctrination at some level.
I think especially for the kids who are applying to these schools and who are
okay with having to score much higher on the sat in order to get a fair chance.
I think they've just been told,
you know,
this is how it has to be.
Um,
but this idea that it should be equality and equality of outcome as opposed to
opportunities is silly and it doesn't actually deal with actual,
um,
differences in terms of opportunity.
You know,
terms of the differences that we see and the reasons why there are these
differences,
they're not actually being addressed.
Please tell me that you got some nice support from members of the Asian
community,
that it wasn't just sort of brainwashed lefties that were,
I didn't,
no,
I didn't.
I got across the board of,
of you know,
many races,
so I was grateful for that because I wasn't sure how people were going to
respond to that piece,
but I felt very strongly that I had to say something
as Harvard issued a response to any of this or do we even know where they're at
with all this?
No,
as far as I know that the lawsuit is still ongoing.
Yeah.
It's just,
it really is just crazy.
So I,
are you with me on this?
I sense that there's some massive minority groups that are breaking right now.
I think the Asian community,
because of the,
I hate saying community,
but you know,
you have to use some words to describe some of this,
but I think the black community is breaking.
This is what a lot of what Candice Owens is talking about.
I sent to this happening in the gay community.
I sent to this happening in the Jewish community on very similarly because of
the Asian community because of hard work and an education and all that.
And so then we decided,
yeah,
we have to put you at the bottom of the oppression Olympics.
Um,
so there's an interesting like strange alliance now,
now building up or are you seeing that?
I could say,
yeah,
I see it coming.
I see.
Well we were talking about the bit about this earlier,
about how the left is going to eat its own until there is only one person left.
So it's only a matter of time really.
We're all going to find each other and say,
yeah,
we've had enough of this.
I mean,
gay men,
you guys don't count.
It doesn't count to begin anymore.
So,
um,
cause I never wanted extra credit.
I wanted equality,
equality.
I wanted equal credit.
Not Extra credit.
Yeah.
So I'm know in a weird way,
I'm actually okay being thrown out in that regard of this pyramid because I
don't want to play that game.
But I think actually finally,
some gay men,
especially gay white men,
because now they're,
they're fully thought of as the enemy.
I mean,
I've even seen things on college campuses where LGBT organizations are saying,
well,
you can't be a gay white man and be the president of the organization because
you're,
you're one of the bad guys.
I mean that,
that's really dangerous thinking.
Well,
I saw what you had to deal with too at that professor who said that the LGBT
community doesn't want you at the,
was it the University of
University of New Hampshire?
Yeah.
Do you know that?
So I didn't know at the time,
so I think much of my audience will,
we'll know what you're referring to.
But I spoke at University of New Hampshire and there were all these heckler's
there,
and there was a trans woman who I did not know was a professor.
I didn't know that until literally two months later who was,
was screaming at me how much I hate trans people and all this.
And I kept saying,
I want you to have equality under the law and I want you to be treated with
decency and respect and I hope you find someone that loves you.
And all of the things I would want for anyone else.
I just don't want the government using a dictating what pronouns I can use to,
to uh,
refer to you.
And you know,
basically she was calling me alt right and all that it too.
And of course it turns out she's a gender studies professor.
Yeah.
I should never be a surprise anymore,
but there's going to be no discipline at the school or anything like that.
I mean,
I could probably make more of a hey at it and see what happens.
It's like,
yeah,
you know,
you handled it amazingly well.
And I mean it's only a matter of time.
Like I see with feminism,
they're turning on white women now too.
So it's insane.
Is that the only logical outcome of these disciplines because they are not held
to the scientific standard of everything else that we discussed here in the
first half that you are held to
scientist.
Yeah.
I think because everything is,
there's so much based in subjective feeling and validating people's experiences.
You apparently can't question someone's experience so someone's offended or they
don't like you.
What can you say?
So I could see that and it's,
it's very much rewarding people for being emotionally driven instead of,
I think the best way to have a debate as to remove emotion and just try to look
at the facts as objectively as you can no matter what the issue is.
So,
um,
it's that is that they don't really have any sort of method to how they do
their,
even their research is,
I mean,
it's kind of a joke.
Yeah.
But are we kind of hearing that even the methods now we're a part of the
patriarchy and all of those things.
Objectivity,
you're using facts.
They,
they,
they don't want facts to actually count because they believe in this postmodern
dribble that,
that facts have been arrived to by mechanisms that they don't believe in.
That's a,
that's a tough thing to trick somebody out of.
Yeah.
But,
you know,
I think on some level,
I think some of these scholars know that what they're doing is very lucrative
and so they're just basically trying to shut people down in any way they can.
They can't really justify it,
but,
you know,
they just keep screaming about it.
And,
uh,
academics who have better things to do,
like actually do real research and they've got their courses and their students
and a million other things and their 80 hour work weeks,
they don't have time to deal with this.
So this is why there's such a lopsided discourse in terms of what you see coming
out of the universities.
And there are some institutions that,
you know,
they won't allow academics to engage with the media without permission for us.
So that,
that's part of it too.
It's just,
it's really an unfair battle right now that's being fought.
Yeah.
How do you think we get to a place where specifically related to sexuality
topics related to gender and sex,
where we will be able to talk about it in a in a better way.
So for example,
the me too movement where everybody every,
I think basically thinking person understands that there were some really bad
people here that did some really bad stuff.
Obviously Harvey Weinstein and Bill Cosby and some people that really,
that that drug people in that you know,
years of history of doing all this and then there's all sorts of other people
who seem like they're just getting swept up in it or basically accused all that.
Now you can be for the idea of the me too movement without being,
for taking down all of these other people also,
and I guess what the real issue is is litigating everyone's history where we
could all look back and go,
I did this,
someone did that to me,
this,
that,
the other thing,
college kids now have an assigned things before they hook up.
I mean really where we're creating this situation where our interpersonal
relations are going to have almost nothing to do with the stuff that's hard
wired into us at the step that you study.
[inaudible] I think me too probably started as something honorable.
And I do agree that women and men have been dealing with harassment for far too
long and that it doesn't get taken seriously sometimes,
but it's to the point now where relations are so strained,
especially between men and women.
I sense men are terrified and that's not going to be helpful across the board
for anybody.
Um,
I think especially when you look at shades of gray,
well,
I mean there's so much I could say on this.
I'm trying to think of what's the best place to start would be.
Um,
with consent.
Say,
I think one message that's been missing is women.
I've written about this.
Women need to advocate for themselves.
And that's not to say if you are experienced harassment or if you were assaulted
that you are at fault.
I'm not advocating victim blaming.
But I think what's missing from this narrative,
women are portrayed as though they're helpless and if something happens to them,
they're helpless.
And that,
uh,
they're basically,
they have no say in terms of how men behave towards them.
And you know,
I've written about sexism in the sciences and how women are basically being
scared off.
I think of going into the field as someone with a phd in a science field.
Yeah.
You deal with sexism and it's unpleasant.
But I still got my degree and now I'm speaking out about it.
So if you want to achieve something,
you can,
a sexism is not so terrible in the world that women can't achieve what they
want.
So going back to consent,
you know,
I think women need,
young women especially need to be told,
you know,
you have a say in this.
If you don't like something or if you don't want to do something,
say so.
Don't,
don't feel like it's on the man to,
um,
I know read your mind and I feel like I'm going to get in so much trouble for
saying this,
but I think that empowers women instead of telling them,
you know,
just really hope that this doesn't happen to you.
And if it does,
then get on Twitter and use the Hashtag and talk about how men are terrible and
men are trash.
Men are not terrible.
They're lovely men in the world.
I love men.
You know,
there are some bad men,
but you can't generalize to all men.
Yeah.
But we love the generalization thing,
right?
That's easy.
I mean,
you even see this,
the amount of articles where I see,
you know,
we have to take down white.
It's always white men.
Yeah.
We have to take down or,
or now it's women's turned to rule the world or all of these things.
And it's like,
well a woman could be president or a woman could be,
you know,
anything that a man could be,
but it shouldn't be because she's a woman.
It should be because she's just qualified,
capable.
But,
but we've seen this sort of hysterical reaction to it and I think that that now
is just another one of these places where we're on this crazy pendulum just
bouncing back and forth.
Yeah.
I'm hoping it's going to come back to the middle.
Um,
and hopefully not too much damage will be done before that happens and that the,
you know,
relations between men and women aren't going to be so terribly strained.
Um,
I do think we're reaching that point though because there are only so many men
left who haven't been accused of a me too moment.
So yeah,
it was only a matter of time.
You know what's interesting,
I have a running joke with some of my friends that I know a lot of great
straight girls in La that are single [inaudible] lot of straight great girls.
I don't know a lot of straight guys that I think are great.
Like,
I know,
I know some straight guys that are kind of whatever,
but I don't know like a lot of straight guys that kind of have their shit
together that are,
so I have all these girls and they're like,
okay,
you set me up with a guy.
And I'm like,
not the guys I know,
which does show that there's sort of a crisis I think in masculinity or
something.
And,
and obviously Jordan Peterson is addressing this at some level,
although now I've spent so much time with him.
I think he's addressing it in a certain way.
You almost equally for men and women,
although people only focus on the male part.
But do you know,
is anyone doing research on sort of what is happening to young men in particular
right now?
Hmm,
that's a good question.
I know that,
uh,
levels of testosterone are lower on average more recently.
So I don't know if that has something to do with it and know what that,
what the reasoning for that is.
Could be.
Maybe there's more estrogens that are,
that we're putting into our bodies.
Um,
trying to think of what I can give you,
cause that's an interesting,
so how old are your friends?
I'm curious.
Um,
this sort of set of friends that I'm talking about.
These girls usually are in,
they're sorta like early thirties.
Yeah.
Kind of thing.
And there,
and they're single,
which,
you know,
most often cases,
a lot of them,
their friends are married already and like they're,
they're on the hunt and they've got good jobs and they look good and they take
care of themselves and all of those things.
And I just don't see the equivalent here.
I don't know,
maybe there's an odd subset of,
because La is like a little bit of an odd place.
Maybe there's more gay people are,
I don't know.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean I could say the average age for people getting married as 28,
so I don't want to,
I don't want to generalize and say that across the board are you sciences that
it's incredible.
I want to be fair.
Yeah.
But I mean,
it could be that for guys who are a certain age and there's a reason,
but at the same thing for women of a certain age,
and not to say live your friends of course,
but um,
you know,
if you're focused on your career and maybe you're not used to giving your time
to someone else,
that could be part of it.
Yeah.
Do you think that the feminist movement,
which I know we sort of,
we've sort of ancillary been talking about it this whole time that they really
did give up something very special by putting so much focus on work and success
in that way.
I mean,
you know,
I think back to my childhood now,
which I think I in retrospect was so amazing.
My mom was home for most of it.
She,
she worked before.
I'm the oldest of three.
She worked before I was there and then she didn't work all the years that she
was raising us and then went back to work after.
Um,
and that having someone at home that was cooking and taking care of us and
making sure we got to school.
And all of those things,
like that's like the greatest thing that anyone could do.
It happens to more often be the woman.
But that's a,
that's a pretty great thing.
That's often been sacrifice.
Now we're thought of it.
It's marked in a way.
Yeah.
I mean I've always been atypical in terms of I've,
I've always been felt more masculine.
I've always been very focused on my career.
Um,
but I definitely think that feminism and for some people it or some proponents
of feminism,
they will denigrate female typical roles and motherhood and wanting to be,
uh,
you know,
at home with your family.
And I think,
you know,
I've heard from women who say,
I've been told that the path to happiness is for me to focus on my career and to
neglect my personal life.
And then they reach a point where they realize,
no,
I do want those things.
And I don't think there should be anything wrong with that.
And the same thing,
you know,
I've written about how there's such an emphasis for,
for girls to be like boys.
Now I saw you tweet about babies.
And underlying that is the sexism that it says that girls need to be like boys
in order to be equal or worthy of respect.
And no one's talking about that where people are just saying,
yeah,
for sure.
Let's just,
you know,
tell girls that they have to be the same as boys and women have to be the same
as men.
Yeah.
So the article you're referring to,
there was this piece,
I think it was a Newsweek that these parents are raising their twins as Fabian's
t h e y babies,
babies.
Uh,
because,
and they're going to let them pick their gender and it's like,
you're going to create more psychological problems then you were trying to hide
them from most likely,
I think.
Yeah.
And it goes back to biology again and,
and hormonal exposure in utero.
You,
I think it's great.
He might've been NBC news.
I think that,
okay.
Yeah.
Newsweek.
Okay.
Yeah.
But yeah,
we think there are a couple outlets that were so excited about this.
Well,
that's what it,
that was why I wrote about it.
Not because of the thing,
you know,
these parents can do whatever they want.
That's what I followed up with immediately after computers can do whatever they
want and then when the children are of age,
they can either decide my parents were crazy or not and just talk like this on
the parents.
Right.
And all that.
But that wasn't the issue for me.
It was that the way these headlines are always written,
it's like this.
It was like this is the new thing and the implicit piece of that is you better
do this to be a good parent and get tolerant parent to be a progressive parent.
And that's what an open minded person and that to me is the danger here.
Not The little isolated case necessarily have these people that are doing
something that's an outlier thing.
Yeah.
And the thing is,
I've heard stories now where people are terrified of giving their daughters
dolls and which is what's really funny is you have some of these really
progressive parents who raise their girls.
They only have gender neutral toys or they give them boys toys and then the girl
obviously goes to school and sees girl typical toys and wants to play with them,
and the parents were horrified and they think,
oh,
this is the patriarchy coming in
the patriots,
just biology.
And we shouldn't be afraid of that and we shouldn't.
We shouldn't shame girls for wanting to be female.
Typical.
Yeah,
but this is why when people say,
I think to a of us that are in this space,
this,
oh,
you guys are overstating what this thing is.
It's just a bunch of angry activist or whatever.
It's like we've seen it.
In fact,
academia would you addressed already?
We've seen it,
in fact,
the home and how you're supposed to raise your kids.
Even just thinking about this now,
it's like,
I think I read something on this and I,
and if not,
there's definite proof of it that Disney made a decision along the way.
Now that they have star wars and marvel,
that star wars was going to be more marketed to girls and marvel was going to be
the boy's thing.
Now,
I'm a big star wars guy and I would see these commercials and it was all girls,
you know,
girls in the ships and girls with the lightsabers.
All right.
I have no problem with that.
Obviously uh,
Ray,
but leading character and last one is a girl.
It's all good that girls can do anything want but,
but pushing marketing on them seems odd to me.
And,
and although I'm sure there are many girl girls out there that want to be a
Jetta I,
there's obviously more boys.
So the way that we even market,
and I suspect they're marketing in a way that's hurting their bottom line in the
name of
tolerance in the name of what I dunno.
Yeah.
So I mean how did the boys feel about that?
Right,
right.
So you're going to get this odd thing then when eventually after enough
marketing boys are going to want to play with the girl thing and then feel weird
about it.
God,
that's
messed up too much time.
Did you have too much time on their hands?
Yeah.
I just say like,
kids do what they want and acknowledge that as long as you give them free
choices,
you probably won't have too much say at the end of the day.
But at least you know,
they,
they'll be happy.
Yeah.
Uh,
is there anything else that you're researching at the moment or that's been on
your mind that,
uh,
that we haven't covered?
Uh,
the only thing I would say is so with wrong speak,
we are going to be launching our second,
we just launched our first season.
Yeah.
Last month.
Um,
so we spoke with James [inaudible],
Lindsay Shepherd.
We also did an episode on rapid onset gender dysphoria.
So it's this phenomenon of adolescent girls who were suddenly saying their
transgender,
even though they've had no previous signs of gender dysphoria and actually their
problems have nothing to do with gender.
So,
so what are the problems?
That's just societal stuff or pressure or wanting attention or what?
All of the above.
Usually autism as well.
So they either will be diagnosed by a mental professional,
but the person will say,
I can't say that I have to,
you know,
affirm your child's gender.
Um,
because they can otherwise get into a lot of trouble and lose their jobs if they
don't.
Um,
wait,
can you repeat that?
I got to get one right so that they will lose their jobs if they know,
but they have to affirm their,
they see,
oh,
they have two clinicians nowadays have to affirm these kids.
If a child says they're transgender and you have to,
they'll lose their jobs otherwise.
So,
so technically a therapist or a clinician could feel that this is some other
issue going on.
Nothing.
But they have to actually affirm what the child says.
Yeah.
The parents and in all the documents.
Yeah,
because they will lose their job because
they're terrified.
And so in Toronto,
what happened?
What the Preston case was,
uh,
my colleague Kenneth Zucker,
I had a clinic where he saw gender dysphoric children and people said that he
was practicing conversion therapy.
He was not.
So conversion therapy I do not stand for,
it's trying to turn gay children straight,
but sexual orientation is not the same thing as gender.
So gender and young children is flexible and it becomes more stable with age.
So when he,
when patients would come to him and say,
you know,
I want to be the opposite sex,
he would say,
okay,
what,
what
underlined you?
Just a rejection.
When you say gender is flexible,
you don't mean the amount of genders.
You mean the feelings that you have related to gender?
Is that yes.
I just want to be clear.
There are two genders.
Let's be clear.
The Ebi I very by,
no,
not as much to jump on that.
Okay.
Um,
so if you have an example you've been using,
if you have a little boy who says he's a girl,
he will likely be a gay man and he will likely grow to be comfortable in his
male gender identity.
So for 99% of us are biological sex is our gender.
Man,
this,
this thing,
it's a,
it's a real monster.
Yeah.
There's a lot of misinformation out there.
So now what I was saying with my colleague has clinic got shut down.
He wasn't doing anything unethical.
But because of that,
it's set this cello across the field.
Now clinicians do not do not want to have the same thing happen to them cause
activists will go after them.
Yeah.
So there's no one really practicing,
uh,
or anyone sort of thought of as legitimate that's practicing conversion therapy
anymore.
Is there,
I hope not.
I hope all the sciences against it,
like the,
that it just never worked.
Like it was just something that I guess is sort of twisted idealogue was
practicing not using real evidence or science and yeah,
I mean it just fizzled out basically.
Yeah.
I do think there are some practitioners who are still doing it.
Not,
I wouldn't call them legitimate,
which it makes me very uncomfortable when I see that.
Um,
but yeah,
definitely sexual orientation is biological.
It's genetic and it can't be changed.
So conversion therapy is completely okay.
Uh,
useless.
Yeah.
Well it's nice.
I'm glad we got there.
At least I think.
I think most people won't be angry at you on that one.
Well,
I guess maybe some people on the right,
maybe might be angle on that one
maybe,
but you know,
I'm all about presenting the data and speaking to facts and the science and
standing up for sex research,
whether it infuriates people on the left or the right.
Yeah.
Science facts reason pretty much,
pretty much all that.
All sort of package within,
within the free speech thing.
Yeah.
That,
can I call you a member of the intellectual dark web?
Please do.
I don't know that I have that power,
but I'm going to go back to the clubhouse later and I'm going to get me a
membership.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
we have to vote on it.
It's a weird thing and we can be a white man some days.
Oh,
right.
That was the thing.
It was like the,
you know,
whatever.
All these idiots that are writing all these nonsensical pieces about,
it's all white men and it's like,
come
on,
there are a bunch of us that are not white,
but I mean they call him,
I've been called a white supremacist.
I've been called a Nazi.
So,
you know,
that's the level that we're at right now,
and they have else.
So I think
it's a good sign.
In a weird way.
It absolutely is a good title.
It's been a pleasure.
I'm so glad that we finally got to do this.
So much fun.
Yeah,
we will.
We will do.
I sent,
these issues are not going away,
so we're going to have to do this again.
All right,
very good.
For more on Deborah,
you can follow her on Twitter.
It's at Deborah Sale.